Most liquids, when cooled,
will simply shrink.
Water, on the other
hand, actually
expands when it is frozen.
Its volume will
increase by about 9%.
Suppose you have 1/3 of a gallon
of water that gets frozen.
What is the volume of the
ice that you now have?
So you're starting with
1/3 of a gallon of water.
They tell us that when it gets
frozen, when it turns into ice,
its volume is going
to expand by 9%.
So the new volume is going
to be your existing volume.
So this is the original
volume, 1/3 of a gallon,
and it's going to expand by 9%.
So your frozen volume is going
to be your original volume
plus 9% of your original volume.
So you could say
it's 9% times 1/3.
So this right over here is
going to be the expanded volume.
Now, there's a bunch of
ways we can figure it out.
We could turn things to
decimals or whatever else,
but they tell us to express
your answer as a fraction.
So let's make sure that
everything here is a fraction,
and then we'll just
try to simplify.
So the one thing that's sitting
here that is not a fraction
is our 9%.
Well, what does 9%
actually represent?
Well, 9% literally
means 9 per 100.
So we could rewrite
this as-- so this
is going to be equal to 1/3
plus, instead of writing 9%,
I'll write that as 9 per 100,
and then once again times 1/3.
And we can simplify this
expression right over here.
We have a 9 in the numerator,
a 3 in the denominator.
If we divide both of them
by 3, we get a 3 and a 1.
And so we're left with
1/3 plus 300 times 1/1.
Well, that's just
going to be 3/100.
So this is just going to
be equal to 1/3 plus-- I'll
write this in orange
still, or maybe I'll
do it in a new
color-- plus 3/100.
And now we have to add
something, or two numbers that
have different denominators.
So let's find a
common denominator.
So this is going to be equal to,
well, the least common multiple
of 3 and 100.
And they share no common factor,
so it's really just going
to be the product of 3 and 100--
the least common multiple is
300.
So it's going to be
something over 300
plus something over 300.
Now to go from 3 to 300, in
the denominator you multiply
by 100, so you have to multiply
the numerator by 100 as well.
So 1/3 is the same
thing as 100/300.
And to go from 100
to 300, we have
to multiply by 3
in the denominator,
so we have to multiply by
3 in the numerator as well.
So 3/100 is the
same thing as 9/300.
And now we're ready to add.
This is going to be 100 plus
9/300, which is 109/300.
So this is the volume
of ice that I now
have expressed as a fraction.